thank you for being with us America this
is the Dave Ramsey show open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five John is with us in Seattle hey Jon
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
thanks for taking my call today sure man
what's up well the only way to describe
my situation is epic fail I'm currently
in about a hundred thousand in consumer
debt making about one hundred and five
thousand a year family of three wife
stay-at-home mom our largest purchase is
uh
2017 truck that I currently go 63,000 on
and we're trying to get rid of
everything so I guess my main question
is what do you think I should do with
the truck I'm looking at negative equity
if I if I sell it sure I'd take out a
personal loan for the remainder yes okay
and you should sell it immediately it's
absolutely ridiculous to have a sixty
three thousand dollar truck and a
hundred thousand dollar household income
regardless of if it was paid for or not
and in this case double ridiculous
because it's got the thing right you
have too much of your money invested in
things going down in value
I'm not against driving a nice truck I
drove you know an f-150 rauch down here
today and it costs more than that but my
income is a whole lot higher in my net
worths a whole lot higher so it's not
even anything to show up on my radar
it's it's it's half three quarters of
your life you know and it doesn't fit
it's killing you the trucks stealing
everything from you and your children
so yeah it's gotta go what is the other
debts one more truck and then twenty one
thousand and forth about eighteen okay
and and so eighty four thousand dollars
of your hundred thousand there's two
trucks yeah okay what I care a little
bit what else I got five thousand in
credit card mm-hmm which is canceled
right now good
five thousand a little over five
thousand on a dirt bike
and then some minor stuff tire accounts
a Lowe's account and leave that's it
well there's two or three things going
on here okay how old are you guys 30 yes
30 years old yeah that's about what
you're about it the you're doing 30 year
old stupid stuff so that's why it's
identifiable all of us all of us do
stupid stuff man
all of us I've done stupid with zeros on
the end I got a PhD in D UMB that's how
I know out what it looks like okay I'm
not making fun of you you it's just
killing you right so here's the thing
how would it feel for you and your wife
and your child to have no payments about
it how quickly country the Financial
Peace University how quick they hurt you
how quickly could you save up and pay
for a fairly nice vehicle or two maybe
even a toy or two if you had no payments
yeah yeah you could and so with that in
mind what we're describing is not a
lifetime jail sentence what we're
describing is when I was a little kid
I'm an old man you may not have ever
played this game but we played a thing
called mother mae-eye
you ever heard of that no and it was a
game you played in the front yard and if
you if you didn't ask permission to step
forward with the director of the game
you had to take to penalty steps back
and that's what you get to do you get to
take to penalty steps back before you go
forward again and so if I woke up in
your shoes knowing what I know now
having done Dumber things than you have
done but gotten the other side of them
and gotten my life back and have a great
life now I would sell all of it the bike
in both trucks and I would get a clone
to cover your upside-down amounts and
then I would work like I get a couple of
beater cars because we're only talking
about less than a year for you to not
only become completely debt-free paying
off those upside-down loans but also be
able to save and have an emergency fund
and then start saving and moving back up
in car here or there
but you and your wife have got to sit
down and decide do you want to keep
living like you're living do you want to
play footsie with this and sorta mess
with it I have these people say I'm
sorta doing the day plan well you can't
sort of do the day plan the day plans
and all in we're playing for the Super
Bowl
wide open deal that's the day plan it
entails not caring what other people
think and I'm gonna go nuts cuz I'm so
sick and tired of being sick and tired
I'm gonna fix this I'm gonna look in my
baby's eyes and say I changed your life
I changed your family tree I'm never
coming back here again
I'm not gonna live like this anymore
that's the day plan dude and if you can
get that down inside of you you can on
it you can do it man now what about your
wife what'd she do it
she's totally game on no can I talk to
her about all the time ever since I
found your show I'm so excited to get
going on it I want you to go through I
want you to go through Financial Peace
University as my guest I'm gonna give it
to you for Christmas or an on week class
okay I just bought it oh you bought it
okay cool good then get you get the kit
pick you out of class you got access to
for a year to all the online videos as
well you can watch a bunch of them even
if you want to before you go to class
but then go to the class anyway and get
signed up for that every dollar plus
it's included for a year where it
connects to your bank and helps you do
the budget all of that's included and
you got a deal on it it's only 129
dollars with free shipping right now so
it's a great deal but good news man good
news well I'll give you a a signed copy
since I you already bought Financial
Peace University of smart money smart
kids so you can teach your child how to
handle money as you're learning how to
handle money so you change your family
tree so hold on and I'll sign a copy of
that and Kelly will send it to you so
very cool man
merry Christmas to you you can do it you
can do this but I would sell the button
to both trucks and a bike and I you know
immediately and not to the dealer and
put them on Craigslist so him for as
much as you can possibly get for him but
let's get out of there let's must make
the change
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]